feminists crave destruction yes
destructive as eradicating the
importance of men in society no I don't
agree okay what do you think um
feminism is made to empower women and
show men the importance of women in
society what's the importance of women
in society what what's the importance of
women in society if it's so important if
you're that's support of empowering
you what's your
role well I'm not being funny um without
where would the world be without women
like where would you you've come from a
woman you've learned most of what you've
growing up who bought you up was it your
mother or your father who's so who's got
core duties why do men go so hard so the
importance of a woman is motherhood